♪♪
>> Jesse: THAT DIDN'T LAST LONG.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE FIGHTING
AGAIN.
AOC SOUNDING LIKE A SULTY
SOCIALIST AT KYRSTEN SINEMA
DITCHED THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND
REGISTERED AS AN INDEPENDENT.
THERE'S NO HEALTHCARE, JUST
VIBES FOR SENATE.
PEOPLE DESERVE MORE.
GOOD OLD BERNIE SANDERS SOUNDS
LIKE HE WILL SICK THE LIBERAL
DOGS ON SINEMA WITH THIS THREAT.
WATCH.
>> I SUPPORT PROGRESSIVE
CANDIDATES ALL OVER THIS
COUNTRY, PEOPLE HAVE THE GUTS TO
TAKE ON POWERFUL SPECIAL
INTERESTS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN
ARIZONA.
WE'LL SEE WHO THEY NOMINATE.
SOMETHING THAT I'LL TAKE A LOOK
AT.
>> PERHAPS WHAT TICKS OFF
LEFTIES THE MOST, SINEMA CAN'T
BE CONTROLLED.
>> I CAN TELL YOU THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS FAILED ITS DUTY
IN THE LAST 40 YEARS.
>> NOT JUST DEMOCRATS.
>> EVERYONE.
>> YOU RAN IN 2020 AND YOU
SUPPORTED HIM.
>> I DID.
I FELT HE WAS THE BEST CANDIDATE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT.
>> SO YOU'RE GOING TO VIEW THE
2024 ELECTION AS AN
INDEPENDENCE.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GO WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE.
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE WHICH ONE
YOU REFER.
>>
>> THAT'S HOW I VIEW EVERYTHING.
>> THIS IS STIRRING UP A LOT OF
DEBATE.
>> Dana: THERE'S NOTHING WE LIKE
MORE THAN INTRAMURAL FIGHTING.
CAN WE TALK ABOUT BEST FOR A
SECOND?
THIS IS A GUY THAT REFUSES TO
DECLARE HIMSELF AS A DEMOCRAT.
HE HIMSELF CALLS HIMSELF AN
INDEPENDENT.
SO WHAT IN THE HECK IS HE
COMPLAINING ABOUT?
IT DRIVES ME NUTS.
ALSO AOC, YOU GUYS SAID NOTHING
WHEN THE LEFT WAS CHASING HER IN
TO THE BATHROOM.
YOU CHASED HER OUT OF THE PARTY
AND NOT YOU'RE GOING TO COMPLAIN
AT IT?
AND KYRSTEN SINEMA IS SMART.
HE WANTS TO STAY IN THE SENATE.
TO STAY, SHE HAD TO BE CLEVER.
ARIZONA HAS SHOWN US THAT THEY
WANT SOMEBODY LIKE HER, THEY'RE
WILLING TO VOTE SOMEONE LIKE
HERE.
THEY DON'T WANT SOMEONE ON THE
FAR LIGHT OR FAR RIGHT.
SO WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS GOING
TO DO?
SHE VOTES WITH THEM 95% OF THE
TIME.
DO YOU WANT THE VOTES OR SHE'S A
LABEL OF A DEMOCRAT.
>> IF YOU PRIMARY HER, YOU'LL GO
DOWN IN FLAMES AND ELECT A
REPUBLICAN SENATOR.
>> Dana: NOW THE REPUBLICANS
HAVE TO BE SMART, TOO?
WHO WILL THEY NOMINATE?
YOU COULD HAVE AN INTERESTING
POLICY ORIENTED CONTEST IN
ARIZONA.
IT'S POSSIBLE.
>> Jesse: VERY GOOD, DANA.
GREG, WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
SINEMA?
>> Greg: I BELIEVE SHE ONCE
DATED KEITH OLBERMANN.
>> Jesse: YOU'RE KIDDING ME.
>> Greg: I WOULDN'T LIE ABOUT
SOMETHING SO DISGUSTING.
EVERY WOMAN IS ALLOWED ONE
MISTAKE IN THEIR DATING LIFE.
I LIKE HOW FEMINISTS ARE ALWAYS
CHANTING TO WOMEN THAT GO TO THE
BEAT OF THEIR OWN DRUM.
WHEN YOU COMPARE AOC TO LIKE
CINEMA, WHO GETS THE GLOSSY
PHOTO SHOOTS?
WHO GOES TO THE GALAS?
IT'S THE GIRL WHO OBEYS.
IT'S NOT SINEMA.
IT'S AOC.
IT'S GREAT.
I THINK THAT LIKE IF A GOOD
PIECE OF ADVICE, IF YOU'RE AT
THE WORKPLACE, JESSE, YOU SHOULD
BE THE KYRSTEN SINEMA OF YOUR
PLACE OF WORK.
YOU KNOW?
PEOPLE HAVE TO PERSUADE YOU.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO PERSUADE
ANYBODY.
SHE'S WORTH 20 AOCs.
YOU KNOW WHEN AOC WILL DO.
SHE'S AN EASY VOTE.
WITH SINEMA, YOU HAVE TO SPEND A
LOT OF TIME TALKING TO HER, A
LOT OF TIME TALKING TO MANCHIN,
RAND PAUL.
ALL THE PEOPLE THAT ARE ON THE
EDGE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT DEMAND
THE MOST ATTENTION.
SO YOU SHOULD ALWAYS BE THAT
WHEREVER YOU ARE.
>> Jesse: DID SHE BECOME A
BISEXUAL AFTER DATING KEITH
OLBERMANN?
>> Greg: WHAT WOULDN'T.
>> Jesse: AS A DEMOCRAT, HAROLD,
THIS IS HAPPENING ON YOUR TURF.
WHAT ARE WE MISSING HERE?
>> YOU TAKE PEOPLE AT THEIR OWN
WORDS.
I LISTEN TO KYRSTEN SINEMA.
SHE SAID 40 YEARS OF FAILURE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I LISTENED TO DANA PERINO.
HE'S NOT A DEMOCRATIC THAT I
GREW UP WITH.
I THINK OF DEMOCRATS IN THE VEIN
OF BOBBY KENNEDY AND BILL
CLINTON.
DEMOCRATS THAT INSPIRED ME IN MY
POLITICS AND DEMOCRATIC POLL 6.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
PROGRESSIVES, THEY HAVE LOST.
REPUBLICANS, YOU TALK ABOUT
DIVISION?
I DON'T KNOW IF KEVIN McCARTHY
WILL BE SPEAKER AND WHAT WILL
HAPPEN TO DONALD TRUMP.
MAYBE WE'LL COVER THAT.
THERE'S NO DOUBT THERE'S
DIVISION IN OUR PARTY.
IT'S THE WING OF THE PARTY THAT
IS MORE -- CLOSER TO SINEMA THAT
IS WINNING.
IF YOU KNOW THAT RIGHT ABOUT
ARIZONA, IF SHE STAYED IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, SHE WOULD FACE
A PROGRESSIVE CHALLENGER.
SHE MAY OR MAY NOT WIN THAT
PRIMARY.
THE ONE THING THAT IS FOR
CERTAIN, THE PROGRESSIVE IS AT A
BIGGER DISADVANTAGE RUNNING IN
THAT RACE THAN SHE IS AS AN
INDEPENDENT.
SO WE SHALL SEE.
I THINK SHE'S SMART.
SHE'S CLEVER.
SHE'S RIGHT ON THE BORDER.
HOPEFULLY NOT ONLY DO LOOKS
LISTEN TO HER, I HELP
REPUBLICANSS WILL AS WELL.
>> Jesse: DO YOU SEE --
>> Harold: DO YOU THINK PEOPLE
WILL MOVE TO THE REPUBLICAN
SIDE?
>> Jeanine: I THINK IT DEPENDS.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS WHAT THE
ESSENCE OF THE PARTY IS.
THEY A TOTALITARIAN.
IF YOU DECIDE --
>> Jesse: SIMPLY PUT.
>> Jeanine: IF YOU DECIDE YOU'RE
GOING TO BE AN INDEPENDENT AND
EVEN IF YOU'RE GOING VOTE WITH
US, 96% OF THE TIME WE'RE GOING
TO TEAR YOU UP, GOING TO PRIMARY
YOU, GOING TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU LOSE.
THAT IS THE DIFFERENCE.
THEY ARE -- IF YOU DON'T BUY
INTO WHAT THEY'RE DOING, YOU
SHOULDN'T BE A SENATOR AT ALL.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE SHOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
LET ME JUST FINISH.
I THINK SHE'S A VERY STRONG
WOMAN.
I THINK SHE'S VERY RESPECTABLE
I SAW WHAT SHE WENT THROUGH WHEN
SHE WAS CHASED INTO BATHROOMS
AND IN AND OUT OF BUILDINGS.
SHE'S A WOMAN MADE OF STEEL.
IF I WERE TO VOTE FOR SOMEONE,
SHE'S THE CANDIDATE -- I DIDN'T
CARE IF YOU'RE MALE OR FEMALE
BECAUSE SHE DOES STAND FOR WHAT
SHE BELIEVES IN.
SHE'S NOT ONE OF THESE PEOPLE
THAT GO TO WASHINGTON AND ONE
HAND WASHES THE OTHER?
I'M ON THIS TEAM AND CHEER LEAD.
SHE'S LIKE I HAVE PEOPLE IN
ARIZONA I HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT.
THERE'S TOWNS IN ARIZONA BEING
OVERRUN.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, I
HAVEN'T HEARD OF DEMOCRATS TALK
ABOUT THE FAILURE OF THE
DEMOCRAT GOVERNMENT IN 30 YEARS.
SHE'S TALKING ABOUT IT.
SHE'S IS AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED
A VERY -- I THINK SHE'S A VERY
INSPIRING WOMAN.
>> Jesse: IMAGINE IF SOMEONE
CHASED THE JUDGE IN TO THE
BATHROOM.
>> Jeanine: I'D BE CHASING THEM
OUT.
>> Harold: SHE'S STILL ON THE
COMMITTEES --
>> Jeanine: IT'S NICE OF HIM.
>> Harold: